alors on ne va pas rentrer dans tous les
détails mais parmi les retours celui du
docteur philippe douste-blazy à la santé
à ses côtés un secrétaire d'état xavier
bertrand chargé du dossier de
l'assurance maladie pour ce député de
l'aisne c'est un premier portefeuille
ministériel avec un dossier très chaud
celui de la réforme envisagée du
fonctionnement de l'assurance maladie
dont le déficit vous savez est abyssal
et mid et lançant ses fans ligne xavier
bertrand ne quitte plus son téléphone
pourtant être secrétaire d'état le
laisse imperturbable le nouveau pourquoi
nouveau d'accord mais je suis nouveau
juste dans les fonctions notre manque
toujours le même pour le même même envie
de travailler même conviction que pour
faire évoluer les choses
si on a choisi c'est pour son sens de la
pédagogie à l'ump xavier bertrand s'est
acquitté de la difficile mission de
faire comprendre le dossier des
retraites au français cette fois c'est
l'assurance maladie qui l'attend
philippe douste-blazy son ministre de
tutelle l'attend lui ce matin l'ump il
est sûr d'avoir trouvé l'homme de la
situation
négocié il écoute il entend ce qu'on lui
dit et il reconnaît sa copie
s'il le faut il a beaucoup d'humilité je
concède une grande qualité aujourd'hui
en politique est à 39 ans ce jeune
député n'a pas peur de la ceinture
dossier exclusif entre c'est la seule
chose quand on manie des explosifs au
pas tremblé nous ne prendrons pas
direction l'avenue de ségur et le
ministère de la santé
cernée par les caméras jean françois
mattei faisait ses adieux sur le perron
xavier bertrand était musique plus qu'un
pincement au coeur c'est quelqu'un que
j'aime bien jean françois xavier
bertrand n'en dira pas plus l'instant
est au recueillement il sait que pour
lui aussi la tâche sera difficile